Mexican drug lord el chapo may have been
recaptured partly thanks to Hollywood
star Sean Penn the actor secretly met up
with the kingpin in a rural part of the
country to interview him a move which
helped the authorities locate the
fugitive pen interviewed him for Rolling
Stone magazine which has tweeted a photo
of the two men together
reports awarding that the following
contains flash photography this is the
story of a Hollywood a-list
biggest narcotics trafficker in the
world
Hakeem Guzman or El Chapo who was
paraded for the media after his recent
recapture worth a billion dollars he's
now on his way back to prison in the
interview pan asks if Guzman's to blame
for high levels of drug addiction
globally El Chapo replies no that is
false because the day I don't exist it's
not going to decrease in any way at all
pan asks him if he's violent the drugs
Lord replies look all I do is defend
myself nothing more but do I start
trouble never Guzman was flown back to
the capital Mexico City there he's being
held in a maximum-security prison but
he's already escaped from there once in
July he was caught on CCTV crossing his
prison cell into a hole beneath the
shower down a tunnel on a motorbike and
away three months later it was reported
he was seen in Durango in a Ferrari with
his sons just days later he was seen in
kisana up in the mountains the net
tightening it's thought he fell off a
cliff while being pursued but was
rescued by bodyguards and his capture on
Friday brought to an end six months on
the run he tried to escape via a drain
but this time the drugs Lord was
captured it's unlikely to change
anything fundamental because the
structure that allows and facilitates
these organizations to operate has not
changed in any sense so if you Charlie
if you capture a major drug trafficker
like El Chapo or if you assassinate
somebody essentially what that does is
it creates a job opening at the top of
the organization America wants Hakeem
Guzman extradited to stand trial there
and Mexico cannot afford the
embarrassment of letting him escape
again El Chapo wants a movie made about
his life hence the contact with Sean
Penn but the authorities were on to him
and so it seems a criminal who deceived
notoriety was undone trying to achieve
celebrity Nick Ravenscroft Sky News
joining us now via Skype is Latin
American historian Benjamin Smith
afternoon to you do you think it was his
vanity that got him in the end then this
time it seems to be Lorna in at the
Pratt was a very interesting interview
with the former killer of Pablo Escobar
the famous Colombian cartel leader who
said rather prescient Lee about three
months ago
I bet it's his vanity that gets him in
the end and it seems to being absolutely
true
can they keep him that's a very good
question I think you know Rob a lot of
it clearly is being made of his escape
they have kept major kingpins in the
past two big examples would be Felix
Guyardo
and Ernesto Fonseca who are kind of the
predecessors of chapo guzman at the same
time they've let chapo escaped twice
once in 2001 and once this year over
last year and also about two years ago
they released Rafael Caro Quintero again
one of his predecessors in the Sinaloa
cartel clearly by mistake so the u.s. is
very worried and thinks that perhaps
they can't keep him in jail which is why
I presume they will try very hard to
extradite him you maybe didn't mean to
Benjamin but you said let him escape do
you think it goes right up to the top
echelon of the government here as to
where his influences we have to do
certain disaggregate the Mexican
government clearly the Mexican
government and the president and members
of the security forces were very serious
about capturing him that's what they
used the Marines we're really the one
trustworthy body within Mexico however
as far as we know according to a very
good report by Mexico leaks it seems
that people very high up in the Ministry
of the Interior were informed about the
escape planned beforehand and did
nothing
does he still hold the same sway with
his gang as he used to or have others
already taken over
um it seems that he does in that was a
very little bloodshed when he came out
if it was the fact that other people had
taken over but one might expect a degree
of conflict between chapo guzman and
these kind of new kids on the block
there didn't seem to be it seems that he
still has enormous charisma and enormous
power over the Sinaloa cartel
so what they're Benjamin will the
Americans do about it
well my expectation is they will put
enormous amounts of diplomatic pressure
and threatened to remove particularly
funding for security if the Mexicans
don't hand him over have the Attorney
General of Mexico has said that they
will hand him over
after he's fulfilled his sentence in
Mexico which he expects will be
somewhere between 300 and 400 years and
drawn out yes indeed
Benjamin's death Smith historian thank
you very much for your time